My name is Camila Batmanghelidjh. I'm a psychotherapist and the founder of Kids Company,...
...a charity supporting 14,000 vulnerable children,...
...and this is See Britain through my eyes.
When we first started, we were a handful of people in some railway arches.
It was 100 adolescent boys from different gangs...
...and I used to just stand here, and kinda take a deep breath, and say, "Welcome,...
...please don't spit." And they used to get their knives out,...
...rip the furniture, set the cushions alight, stick their chewing gums in places.
But as time went on, I got to know them and they started coming and talking to me,...
...and it's just in this little railway arch, I heard 400 of the most horrific stories...
...of what had happened to these children.
So, we quietly, gently, and eccentrically grew to a big organization.
Now, we've got a five story building as our head office.
We're on 40 different sites, 6,000 volunteers, 14,000 children who are being helped,...
...a budget of 12 million and this is all thanks to the British public...
...because every brick of Kids Company was built on the compassion of the British public.
What we do at Kids Company is that we function like a substitute parent in the lives of these children.
Some of the children are so disturbed and traumatized...
...that we need to untangle the trauma before they can go on to flourish.
When I was nine years old in Iran, I told my parents that I wanted to start an orphanage,...
...but then the revolution happened in Iran, and I ended up in England.
I had to get political asylum.
Even though I had significant damage to my brain because of being born very premature,...
...I walked out of Warwick with a first-class degree,...
...which then opened all the other doors.
So now, I have six secretaries and I don't care if I can't spell.